BANJOT CHANANA: Hi, everyone.
Welcome to the Cloud
Operations Spotlight.
My name is Banjot
Chanana, I'm one
of the leads for CloudOps
focused on monitoring.
RAMI SHALOM: Hi everyone.
My name is Rami Shalom, and I
am a PM Lead in Cloud Operations
focusing on logging and APM.
Today we're going to talk about
Cloud Operations in Google.
We're going to recap
about everything that we
have done in the past year.
We're going to demonstrate
the most exciting features
so we'll be able to experience
this more accurately.
And then we're going to
talk about our roadmap,
the new exciting
things that we're going
to work on in the next year.
And some customer highlights,
how they actually use
the product and [INAUDIBLE].
So what is CloudOps, and
what happened to Stackdriver?
So we rebranded, and
with this rebranding
we've done some significant
changes in that product
to justify this rebranding.
So Cloud Operations
is still a suite
of products designed to monitor,
troubleshoot, and operate
your services at scale.
Cloud Operations help developers
and operators-- so you guys--
keep your applications
fast and available.
The Suite includes
three main products.
First one is monitoring.
Monitoring is a framework
to be able to monitor
your metrics, dashboards,
uptime checks, and alerts.
Whereas logging
is a platform that
allows you to manage your logs,
analyze them, and get the most
value out of them.
And then we have
traces, which allows
you to manage your trace.
One more piece to
the mention here
is that those products are
part of a single suite that
allow you to do a
cross-single correlation.
Banjot, why don't
you tell us about how
scalable this platform is?
BANJOT CHANANA:
Yeah, folks may be
asking what makes
us so different from
every other product out there?
And these products were
born from inside Google.
So a lot of the capabilities
you see here today
were actually developed
for Google by Google.
And what we're doing is
exposing those same capabilities
to you, our customers.
And so the scale in which Google
operates, as you can imagine,
is quite large.
We've taken that same scalable
back end infrastructure,
and we've now oriented
that to you, our customers.
So we can provide you the
same planet-level scale
that we provide to
our own websites
to our own capabilities
and our own applications.
Now, some of the stats
that might astound you
about how much data
we take in today,
50 trillion metric
points in memory
are stored for all the
ingest volume that comes in.
And we've got over 2 and 1/2
exabytes per month of logs
that enter the system
and that can be analyzed.
So this just gives you an
idea of the type of scale
that we can operate at.
Now, along with that scale,
what we've been able to do
is ensure that when you
stand out your services
on Google Cloud,
that you don't have
to put much effort into
ensuring logging and monitoring.
And advanced
observability capabilities
are available on the
first day you start out.
So there's built in capabilities
for all of your Google Cloud
Services, and zero config needed
to get those up and running.
So that first day that a
new Google Service comes up,
the next Google Cloud
offering, you'll
have all the metrics and logs
for all the services available.
As soon as it is GA.
Let's talk a little
bit about what
we've been doing since
last year at Next to 2019.
We really took a
focus on CloudOps
around three big
areas the first was
around Enterprise Readiness.
We wanted to make sure
that our capabilities allow
for you, our customers,
to comply with all
of your corporate regulations
and compliance rules that you
need in order to
make sure it fully
integrates with the systems
that you already have today.
So whether it's providing
longer term retention
for logs and metrics, or
whether it's deeper integration
into third party systems,
we provided a lot
of the capabilities
that make sure
that you can tie this in to the
systems that you already have,
and make that transition to
the Cloud that much easier.
We focused on ease of use.
We wanted to make sure
that the products are
easy and simple to use
for even non-power users.
For those that are using
logs and metrics and traces
for the first time.
And so you'll see
a lot of the work
we've done to simplify
the user interface,
and to make it easier to get
to the root cause of what's
going on in your systems.
And lastly, we focused on GCP.
We wanted to make sure that
every service in GCPs--
all the logs and
the metrics that
are necessary to
troubleshoot what's
going on with the infrastructure
that you know align--
are available to you on day one.
And so we deeply
integrated with all
of the GCP services from
BigQuery to Google Compute
Engine to GKE or
Kubernetes Engine
and a variety of other services.
So on day zero all of
those are ready for you.
Let's get one of
those integrations
we did for ease of use.
We took the entire
Cloud Monitoring Console
that was previously
in a separate UI
and a separate browser--
we brought that into the
Google Cloud Console.
In the same context as all
the other services we use.
Compute Engine BigQuery, GKE.
With that in-context capability,
you now have full visibility
to all of your metrics,
and we improved
a number of the interfaces
around Cloud Monitoring
so it's easier to get to your
dashboards, to your alerts,
and to your uptime checks
from one single place.
And you can very easily
then switch back and forth
between Cloud Monitoring and all
the rest of your Google Cloud
Services.
Rami, why don't you
talk a little bit
about some of the work you
did on Log Viewer as well.
RAMI SHALOM: Thanks Banjot.
Similar to what we have
done on the monitoring side,
we have invested heavily
in the Log Viewer.
We actually rebuilt the
product from the ground up
to optimize it for performance
and responsiveness.
So your experience
with the new Log Viewer
should be way better
and easier to work with.
We also invested in
some key components
that will allow you to
better analyze your data.
Get the essence of what you
are experiencing and will
be looking for in your
logs directly from the UI
that you have there.
So we invested in
the histogram that
allows you to see the time
distribution of your logs.
So we'd be able to see
exactly when, there
is a spike of errors.
We have invested in
the Log Field Explorer
to allow you to see
aggregation of your logs
based on field values.
So this gives you a
highlight view of everything
that happens there.
We have invested in
how streaming operates.
We're going to talk
about this a bit later.
We've invested in a
query library that
will allow you to
manage your queries,
because you want to repeat
your work sometimes and get
some recommendations about that.
And we have been a
bunch of other things
we're going to talk
about in depth.
Other than that, we also
created the New Log Dashboard.
This is a great
example of how we
do the integration between
monitoring, logging,
and traces.
In this case, it's
producing a dashboard
that is focusing on logs
inside the logging UI,
but relying on the metrics that
happen in Cloud Monitoring.
Banjot, why don't you tell
us about SLO monitoring?
BANJOT CHANANA:
Yeah, SLO monitoring
is a great new feature we've
added to really help you reduce
the signal to noise ratio.
So as you add more
and more signals--
whether it's metrics and logs
from your existing workloads--
it gets harder and harder
to really find the root
cause of what's happening.
And really what we
want to do is ensure
that our services are being
measured by how our users are
experiencing those services.
Service level objectives is
focused on doing exactly that.
It's ensuring that you look
at the same measurements
and experience it the
same way as your users do,
by automatically ingesting
the services that
are created on your
GKE-deployed applications.
Whether it be through GKE
Labels and Namespaces,
or if you're using our advanced
capabilities with Istio
and Anthos Service
Mesh, we automatically
find those services.
And then you can quickly create
availability and performance
metrics and collect those
to create your service level
indicators, to
which you can then
apply an objective
and a threshold
that you can alert on.
What this also does
is allows you to see
a single view of that service.
So you can see all
the entities that
compose that service
and all the signals
related to those entities.
The logs, the metrics, and
the traces all in one place.
And we give you that
single pane of glass
to ensure that you can
troubleshoot that service
and quickly get to a
resolution on any issue
that you might be experiencing.
Now, we've also made this
easier for our system
administrators and
our IT operators, who
have to go through
and instrument
all of their applications
and all of their VMs
to ensure they can
collect those metrics.
We've provided this new
Ops Config Agent where
you can define the automation
lifecycle for this agent
itself, and ensure
that the right VMs get
the right agents with
the right versions,
and they're
automatically installed.
And that policy is
enforced throughout all
your VM instances.
And you see a sample
policy command here
that defines which VMs--
in this case all VMs--
get installed agents that
are particular to the logging
and monitoring agents--
the versions of those agents--
and you can decide whether
those agents automatically
upgrade when new
versions are available.
And then lastly,
for our power users,
we added the new
Metrics Query Language.
This gives users who are
really taking their metrics
to a new level and looking
to do much more complicated
alerting and
mathematical operations
on times series data--
provides them the ability
to perform those operations
by doing things like allowing
you to do ratios and time
shift on your data.
To do month over month or
year over year analysis.
Or in the case of ratios,
to be able to define
a certain new service level
indicators for your service.
It allows for complex
grouping and filtering,
so you can take that
data and pivot it
in a number of different
ways, depending
on the metric labels you have
and the types of resources
that you're looking at.
So this really
enables power users
to find what they need within
the time series data they get.
And the more data you
collect, the easier
it is to use the Metrics Query
Language to look and sift
through that data to find
what you're looking for.
RAMI SHALOM: Right.
We've also invested in the power
users in the logging framework.
One notable feature-- maybe
looking tiny but quite
requested by our
customers, by you guys--
is the ability to use regular
expressions within the log
queries.
So today it's available, You are
able to use regular expressions
to identify patterns and
make your queries more
specific and more efficient
to find exactly what you're
looking for.
And we have seen
tremendous traction
with customers
using that feature.
Other than that,
many of you have
been asking us to add the
streaming feature into the Log
Viewer.
So we didn't just do that.
We actually decided to
invest in it further.
So we created a new
API in the product
that allows you to get
a much better latency.
From 13 seconds
waiting for logs,
now you're going to wait
for less than two seconds.
The way it's done is
that we have shortcut
at some of the steps along
the ingestion pipeline
logs, and get them
straight to the UI
for you to be able
to ingest those logs
and see them right in the UI.
So you're not going
to wait for them.
When you're running
your code, it's
going to appear as soon as
the application generates it.
The next one is Log Buckets.
One of the key
features that customers
have been asking us is to manage
the logs in a way that fits
their needs in a better way.
More specifically, Log
Buckets is a new contract
that allows you to store
the logs, first of all
in a centralized fashion.
You can collect all the
logs from all the projects
that you have and put them
in one bucket if you wish,
in a way that will allow
you to centralize your logs.
However, Buckets is also allow
you to do the other way around,
which is basically
decentralize everything.
You may want to have a
bucket or a scope of logs
dedicated for application.
So Log Buckets are going to
give you that enablement.
But other than
that, Log Buckets,
as a physical contract,
can be stored regionally.
Which means you can decide that
the certain bucket is not going
to leave a certain region.
That's good for compliance
purposes in some regions,
but it also is useful for
the case of redundancy.
You may want to have full
tolerance between two
different regions.
So you can put the same data
in two different buckets,
and store it in two
different regions.
The last piece is
that the Log Buckets
will allow us also to offer
you granular permissions
for those buckets.
So you'd be able to decide
which users can access which
logs assigned to which bucket.
And we actually intend
to do more than that.
We're going to introduce the
concept of Log Views, which
will allow you to get
even more granular access
control in the logs in
each and every bucket.
The last piece I'm going
to mention related to APM
is cross-signal coordination
across traces, metrics,
and logs.
Right now, you'll be able
to see that we are going
to be able to access metrics--
sorry, prices-- right from
your monitoring dashboards
or right from your logs
whenever they are available.
And you're going to get a
sense that this is actually
available.
You're going to get the signal
that the trace is available
and you can click on it and
see exactly the waterfall
of the latency that happens
inside your application.
And with that, why don't
we go through a quick demo
to show the main features that
we are doing in the products.
Welcome everybody.
In this demo, we will
walk you through the new
and the most exciting
features in Google Cloud
Operations we have been
working on for the past year.
As you will see, we
have been working hard
to improve your experience
and productivity,
as you'll observe and
troubleshoot your applications.
We will start our journey
in Cloud Monitoring,
and we'll focus our
attention on services.
In this page, you will
notice a range of services.
Some of them are automatically
identified by the systems,
and others were
defined by the users.
Let's focus our attention
on those services
that look like that could
deserve some attention.
More specifically, let's focus
our attention on Ad Service.
This service appears to be
in distress in the sense
that it's not meeting our
service-level objective.
And we want to take a closer
look at what's happening.
At the top of the page, you
will notice the alert timeline
component.
This component allows you to
review all the alerts that
have been fired for this
service, along this timeline,
and drill down as needed.
Below the alert timeline, you
will notice the SLO component.
This component
allows you to review
SLOs that have been
defined for this service.
It also allows you
to create a new SLO
by choosing the
metrics of your choice
as well as the criteria
of your choice.
In this case, we can
notice that the service--
the ad service-- is out
of our budget, which means
it deserves our attention.
And we need to drill down
further to see what's going on.
Below the SLO component, you
will notice the key metrics
component.
This component presents
to you the metrics that
are collected for this service.
You can review those
metrics at multiple levels
depending on what
you are looking for.
You can do it at the
container, at the pod,
or at the node level.
These key metrics can
offer valuable insights
about what may be wrong
with your service.
So that could be a
good starting point
to further explore or
troubleshoot your service.
Below the metrics widget, you
will notice the logs widget.
This widget allows
you to explore
the logs that are produced by
the service, which can provide
valuable context
related to every issue
that this service
is experiencing.
For greater details, and
deeper analysis of those logs,
you can choose to open the
logs in the Log Viewer.
We will begin our
journey in Cloud Logging
by presenting the key
components on the page.
The first one is the Log Viewer,
or where the logs are actually
presented.
This is where you will
see all the logs that
are collected by the
system, and you'll
be able to browse through that.
You will then notice the
histogram, which gives you
a time-based distribution of the
logs that are presented below.
Lastly, there is the
Log Field Explorer.
This widget presents to
you an aggregation view
based on field values
in the logs that
appear in the log widget.
To begin our
troubleshooting journey,
we will start with
selecting the resource that
is of interest to us based
on the logs that we see.
I am interested in
Kubernetes Container,
so I'm going to click that.
And you will notice that
this resource is now
added to the query.
Also, I am interested
in errors that
are happening in my
application, so I'm
going to click that as well.
And you will notice that
there is a cluster of errors
that appear at
different points in time
along the last six hours.
At this point, we may choose to
narrow the results down further
based on the time range that
we are interested in the most.
Or we can simply
focus on the logs
that appear on screen because
the number is small enough.
At this point we can just
get rid of everything
else other than
logs and focus just
on the logs that
appear on screen.
Another option to reach
this narrow set of results
could be via the Log Dashboard.
The Log Dashboard
is a component that
allows you to see an
aggregation of logs
over time, based on specific
resources and specific types
of logs.
On the left side, you'll
see the overall logs that
are generated in the
resource, on the right side,
you will notice the errors that
are generated for the service.
This dashboard allows you to
click on one of those bars
and view the logs that
are related to that.
What will happen is that
we'll jump to the Log Viewer
presenting the errors
or the logs that
are related to the specific
bar that I selected.
You've probably noticed
that up to this point,
I didn't interact with
the Query Builder, which
allows me to actually edit the
specific text inside the query
and construct it
the way I want to.
You can further adjust your
query by either editing
the text directly in
the query builder--
and change any of the
fields that appear there--
or use the menus to
construct your query
based on the resources,
the log name,
or the severity of the logs
that you're interested in.
You'll also notice
a new functionality
that we have added to
manage your queries.
Beside the Query
Builder you will notice
a query library that allows you
to review your recent queries
and relaunch them if you
want to, save queries--
queries that you decided
to save and share
with other users in the
project, and suggested queries.
Those are queries
that we actually
suggest to you based on our
understanding of your logs.
Last but not least, I would
like to turn your attention
to the streaming functionality
in the Log Viewer.
This feature allows
you to visualize logs
as they are being generated
by the application.
The delay time is
seconds, which allows
you to troubleshoot your
applications way more
efficiently.
Thanks for listening.
We will now go back
to the presentation
and continue our
discussion focusing
on the roadmap for
Cloud Operations.
BANJOT CHANANA: That was a great
demo Rami, thanks for that.
Let's now talking about what's
coming next for CloudOps.
We've got some
exciting new features
that we think will make it
really easy for our users
to now take advantage of
all the great capabilities
in our product suite.
We'll start with Simplified
Dashboard and Alert Creation.
We find that many users
have a hard time getting
to their first dashboard because
they don't know what metrics
to use, or they don't quite know
how to visualize those metrics
in a way that makes sense.
So we provide a basic
mode that allows
you to get a guided prescriptive
flow to deciding which metrics
to choose using the most
commonly accessed metrics
for your GCP services.
And then providing
recommendations
for how to visualize those
metrics in a chart that makes
sense to you.
We'll also provide the
advanced capabilities
so you can continue to use
the dials and knobs to get all
the right alignment and
grouping and filtering
that you need to, to get
the most out of your data
as you become more
and more advanced
on your usage of the
dashboard capabilities.
And of course, you'll
have the Query Language
to do even more complex
queries and arithmetic
operations that you can't do
through the user interface.
We'll provide a
grid-based layout,
so you can quickly drag
and drop your charts
wherever you want to.
And make sure that right
charts get the right attention
and they stay in
the right place.
Where they can get
sized as big or as small
as you need them to.
And we've added
additional chart types,
so you can use
things like heat maps
to find out where
problems are in a very
complicated metric series.
Or our charts scorecards and
other text-based place holders
to make your charts
work for you.
We're also looking
forward to providing
additional multi-signal
correlation
using topology information.
Today, we can take a look
at all the microservices
that you've got running in
your GKE cluster as an example,
and map that out in
this topology graph.
That topology
graph will give you
a great sense of the dependency
between your microservices
and which service
is communicating
with which other service.
Now, that's great for
configuration and for looking
at static display, but
what we'd really like to do
is layer on additional
information about latency,
service uptime, and error rates.
So you can quickly
diagnose and find
the problems that matter
between your microservices.
And as it gets more
and more complicated
across your real estate
of your applications,
we can use the topology graph
to simplify where to look
and how to find the right
problem to solve for.
And then with Proactive
Alerts and Remediation,
we want to be able to
really get the system
to work for you instead of
just working alongside you.
So with Automated
Alert Creation,
the system will
recommend the types
of alerts you should create for
the GCP services that you have.
So on day zero, you have the
best practices configuration
ready to go.
You can of course,
configure those alerts
in ways that make sense to
you, but at least you're
provided the recommended
way to look at a service
that you may be looking
at for the first time.
With Log-based Alerts,
you'll be able to quickly get
notifications on events that
happen inside your logs.
So instead of having to
turn those logs into metrics
and then explore them
through the Metrics Explorer,
you can now just
assign alerts based
on patterns and
combinations you see
in the structure of
the logs themselves.
With Alert
Remediation, we can now
do typical workflow functions.
So as an alert
fires, wouldn't it
be great if the system
just handled some
of the common issues for you?
So when a CPU--
when a VM runs out of CPU
or it runs out of disc,
why not just resize the VM?
If you had bad
deployment in GKE,
and the application is
continuing to service and throw
errors, why not redeploy based
on the last known good state
of that application?
Or something more complicated
that you've already triaged
and understand how
to fix, you could
write your own Cloud
Function and execute that
from the alerts themselves.
And lastly, with
Anomaly-based Alerting,
we really want the
system to work for you.
And really get ahead of problems
before they become problems.
So with Anomaly-based
Alerting we'll
threshold or baseline the system
and set automated thresholds
for when we see the system
deviating from normals that we
are viewing year over
year, month over month,
and day over day.
And this is leveraging all
of the great machine learning
capabilities inside of Google.
Rami, why don't you
tell us a little bit
about what's happening on
the log side of the house?
RAMI SHALOM: Thanks Banjot,
wow, you have a lot going on.
Let's talk what's happening
on the Log Insight then.
So we will continue
the effort of making
the insight, our
logs, more readily
available for you to use.
At this point, it's
more following your lead
when it comes to what
logs you're looking for.
Our plans forward is to drive
those insights out of the box
without you trying to
figure out what's going on.
So for instance, when
we see a certain scope
of logs in your Log Viewer,
we will service proactively
the trends that are
related to this.
If there is a bunch
of errors that people
want to be aware
of, or a resource
that is an outstanding resource.
Or if there is a
field that we see
that is providing the certain
insight that we will want
to service to you,
those are the types
of things we're
going to show you out
of the box within
Cloud Logging, using
visual mechanisms to that.
Maybe more importantly,
one of the key investments
that we have right now in Cloud
Logging is our [AUDIO OUT]..
This is a smart
analytics at Cloud-scale,
using SQL relying on BigQuery.
So the idea is that
first of all, we
want to allow you to
have a richer language
to analyze your logs.
In some cases, you will want
to do more than just filtering
of your logs.
We will want you to do
aggregations, and allow
you to do more sophisticated
operations on your logs.
For that you will need SQL.
We will use BigQuery
as a back end
to be able to run SQL
operations in Cloud Logging,
in the context, and all the
power and visualizations
that we have in Cloud Logging.
We will also allow you
to use the same data
in the logging that is
going to be useful for you
as part of your
BigQuery analysis.
So for instance, if you want to
do business analytics involving
multiple repositories of data,
you will be able to do this.
So combining log data, for
instance, with identities.
Or combining log data with other
parts of your business data
is going to be available
inside BigQuery
and seamlessly
from Cloud Logging.
Performance improvements
rely on the fact
that we will be able to use
the BigQuery framework to do
better indexing, and
the analysis of bigger
chunks of data at faster rates.
This is one of the things that
BigQuery is really powerful at,
and we want to make
sure that we fully
leverage that capability as part
of our Cloud Logging capability
as well.
Banjot, why don't you tell
us about how customers
are using our features?
BANJOT CHANANA: Yeah, it's
great to have customers really
tell the story.
Because we as product managers,
we of course love our products.
And we love building
these capabilities.
But really, it's up to
our customers to tell us
whether these features make
sense or don't make sense.
So don't take our word for it.
Hear their stories.
We're all talking
here at Cloud Next,
so I'll call out a
couple of customers
here that we've
been working closely
with that are really
taking advantage
of some of our capabilities.
With Equifax, Shopify,
Wix, and Schlumberger,
each have their own
story how they've
leveraged parts of
the CloudOps Suite,
and are taking advantage of
the capabilities we have today.
So look for them in their
respective sessions.
And of course,
there's a whole series
of tracks and other sessions
from which you can learn more
about everything we've talked
about in our Cloud Spotlight
Session today.
So if you want more
information, or you
want to hear directly
from our customers
and hear more about what
your peers are doing
in the industry, these
are the tracks in which
you can find more information.
Between the infrastructure
and app modernization tracks,
we think you'll find a
ton of great information.
And with that, we thank
you for your time today.
And we hope you get the
most out of this session,
as well as the rest of the
tracks through Cloud Next.
RAMI SHALOM: Thank
you, everyone.
And thanks for staying with us.